[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y
esto es aquí América el programa de
France 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y Estos son nuestros
titulares
el régimen de Daniel Ortega desterró A
222 opositores nicaragüenses que
mantenía arrestados los envió en un
avión a Estados Unidos y les quitó la
nacionalidad la Unión Americana los
acogió con una visa humanitaria y el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
entregó su tercer discurso del estado de
la unión en la mitad de su mandato ante
un congreso que ya no controla en su
totalidad debido a que su partido el
demócrata perdió el control de la cámara
de representantes en las elecciones de
noviembre
y el continente americano de norte a sur
se solidariza con chile que vive una
emergencia por los incendios que dejan
más de dos decenas de Muertos la enviada
especial de France 24 habló con los
rescatistas mexicanos los topos que
luchan por controlar las llamas
íbamos de inmediato a hablar de
Nicaragua el régimen de Daniel Ortega
desterró A 222 presos políticos los
subió a un avión con destino a
Washington y despojó a los nicaragüenses
de su nacionalidad se trata de
opositores excandidatos presidenciales
religiosos todo tipo de personas que
solamente alzaron su voz en contra de
las violaciones a las libertades y la
acumulación de poder por parte de Ortega
quien los acusa por su parte de traición
a la patria la administración de Joe
biden les otorgó una visa humanitaria y
Consideró que este destierro que es una
violación a los Derechos Humanos es una
señal positiva escuchemos lo que dijo
biden en una entrevista con la cadena
Telemundo
creemos que todos los prisioneros
políticos deben ser liberados ahora si
esto es una muestra de que están listos
para empezar a cambiar su política de
derechos humanos o no Aún está por verse
pero por el hecho de que fueron
liberados estamos felices felices de
recibirlos y felices de que estén libres
a su llegada a Estados Unidos los
nicaragüenses afirmaron que no tenía
ni idea sucediendo y mucho menos que
iban a ser despojados de su nacionalidad
escuchemos sus palabras dice
textualmente ahora el artículo 29 de la
Constitución que los traidores a la
patria pierden la calidad de ciudadanos
nicaragüense Qué significa para eso yo
yo creo que que son palabras son
palabras la nicaraguanidad se lleva
Yo diría que hasta espiritualmente O sea
no es un asunto de una ley aprobada por
la asamblea Yo seré nicaragüense hasta
el día que me muera y voy a seguir
amando a Nicaragua
no solamente como la nación donde nací
sino como la tierra que Deseo ver en
democracia y mientras que Estados Unidos
lo ve como una señal positiva el derecho
a una nacionalidad es un derecho
fundamental organizaciones defensoras de
los Derechos Humanos así como la
Organización de Estados Americanos la
oea criticaron esta medida de destierro
que Data de la Edad Media hablamos al
respecto con Dani Ramírez ayer dice él
es un activista y profesor especializado
en Derechos Humanos eso fue lo que nos
dijo estas personas habían sufrido
del despojo de sus derechos
fundamentales y habían sufrido la
persecución por parte del gobierno de
Nicaragua leyes hechas a la medida de la
de la oposición nicaragüense desde el
año
2019 y ahora lo que vemos es esta figura
de El destierro en Nicaragua no existe
en el código penal la figura del
destierro sin embargo hoy fue
fue realizada al margen de cualquier
legalidad De hecho también ellos fueron
impedidos de los Derechos políticos y
los derechos ciudadanos e inhabilitados
para siempre sin embargo lo habíamos
dicho desde nuestra organización desde
Cali que el gobierno está regresando a
tiempos tan lejanos como la colonia al
imponer este tipo de penas como la el
destierro y la inhabilitación perpetua
para ejercer derechos ciudadanos o
políticos Mientras tanto Ortega mantuvo
su discurso de que se trataba de
traidores a la patria recordemos que
entre los expulsados se encuentran ex
dirigentes sandinistas como Dora María
Téllez ex candidatos presidenciales
opositores y algunos estudiantes que
lideraron las protestas en contra de
Ortega en 2018 Ortega negó que se
tratara de una negociación con la Casa
Blanca
no estamos pidiendo nada a cambio
en un asunto de honor de dignidad de
Patriotismo que se llevan a sus
mercenarios aquí no ha habido ninguna
negociación esto debe quedar claro
porque la soberanía del país
la dignidad de la patria
no se negocia te desconoce que recibió
el régimen de Daniel Ortega A cambio de
estas liberaciones por parte de la
administración de Joe biden entre tanto
esta semana el presidente estadounidense
entregó su tercer discurso del estado de
la unión ante el congreso en Washington
aunque los republicanos que ahora tienen
la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes lo abuchearon el
mandatario mantuvo un discurso optimista
y dejó entrever que a pesar de su edad y
de que había descartado inicialmente
hacerlo podría aspirar a la reelección
en 2024 biden volvió a enfocar su
discurso en la economía resaltó sus
objetivos logrados como haber rebajado
la tasa de inflación y los índices de
desempleo escuchemos parte de lo que
dijo
hace dos años la economía se tambaleaba
estoy aquí esta noche después de haber
creado con la ayuda de muchas personas
en esta sala 12 millones de nuevos
puestos de trabajo más empleos creados
en dos años que cualquier presidente
haya creado en cuatro años
[Aplausos]
la inflación ha estado cayendo todos los
meses Durante los últimos seis meses
Mientras que el salario neto ha
aumentado
[Música]
la protección de los afro
estadounidenses ante la violencia
policial el derecho al aborto a nivel
Federal la guerra en Ucrania y el
desafío de China también Fueron
abordados por el presidente de
estadounidense en este discurso en un
tono de defensa de objetivos cumplidos
mientras que la tradicional réplica
republicana estuvo a cargo de la
gobernadora de Arkansas
quien también fuera secretaria de prensa
de la Casa Blanca durante la
administración de Donald Trump y tildó a
los demócratas de radicales pintó el
panorama de un país profundamente
dividido
Estados Unidos es grandioso porque somos
libres pero hoy nuestra libertad está
bajo ataque y el Estados Unidos que
amamos está en peligro el presidente
biden y los demócratas les han fallado y
es hora de un cambio una nueva
generación de líderes republicanos está
dando un paso adelante no para ser
Guardianes del statu quo sino para ser
creadores de cambios para el pueblo
estadounidense
vamos a Colombia donde el gobierno de
Gustavo Petro trata de avanzar con su
llamado proyecto de paz total en este
contexto informó que alcanzó un acuerdo
de cese el fuego con una de las mayores
disidencias de las FARC que se cree que
tiene cerca de 3.200 personas en armas y
nació cuando dos dirigentes de las FARC
decidieron no firmar el acuerdo de paz
alcanzado entre la administración del
expresidente Juan Manuel Santos y el
grupo guerrillero este acuerdo no
incluye a las disidencias comandadas por
otro grupo comandado por Iván Márquez
una de las principales figuras del
extinto grupo guerrillero visitemos
chile que atraviesa una catástrofe por
los incendios más de 300.000 hectáreas
consumidas en una semana que también ha
dejado más de dos decenas de Muertos más
de 2000 heridos y más de 1000 casas
destruidas equipos de Argentina de
España Ecuador e incluso Venezuela han
llegado a combatir las llamas también
300 brigadistas especialistas del
ejército de México conocidos Como los
topos su éxito en los rescates los ha
llevado a tener fama internacional la
corresponsal de France 24 en Chile
Patricia Luna habló con ellos y nos
envió el siguiente reportaje
chile se quema tres regiones la
araucanía bío bío y ñuble se encuentran
bajo estado de catástrofe por los
incendios que hacen más de una semana
asolan al centro sur del país se
combaten más de 300 con múltiples focos
un número variable diario de entre 70 y
90 de ellos muy activos pero los
chilenos no están solos tropas y
brigadistas llegados de toda América
Latina también de España ayudan en el
combate del fuego como los muy conocidos
topos del ejército mexicano por su gran
maestría frente a las llamas
Francisco rico ingeniero de la comisión
forestal de México está encargado de dar
órdenes para controlar un peligroso
incendio que se acerca a la ciudad de
Concepción ayudar a la gente ayer ayer
estuvimos evacuando algunas áreas con
las casas nos preocupaba Antier vimos
casas quemadas tuvimos que se siente feo
e impotente de no poder acercarnos
también por seguridad propia pero eso es
lo que nos motiva de poder ayudar a la
gente y que y que ojalá que sus casas el
medio ambiente los ecosistemas se puedan
conservar
los bomberos mexicanos son claves para
controlar un foco de incendio utilizando
el mismo fuego para cortar el avance de
las llamas direccionándolas y son
alardeados y agradecidos por los autos
que transitan la carretera y les envían
ánimo la verdad es de gran apoyo
al mínimo darnos un este un saludo ya
que nos sube mucho la moral estando en
otro país la gente se ha portado muy
bien con nosotros tras la ayuda en el
combate de los incendios la hospitalidad
chilena se deja sentir vecinos de la
zona organizan un carrito de comida
típica chilena los completos o hot dogs
con aguacate como un pequeño gesto para
agradecer La dedicación y ayuda a
algunos de los 300 bomberos y
especialistas del ejército mexicano
desplazados a Chile me siento uno muy
contento porque pues representar a nivel
internacional a un país y venir a
prestar el apoyo en el momento en que
desafortunadamente verdad se tiene que
pues es grato de verdad es grato y te
digo la hospitalidad vaya más amable de
un hecho que sigue destruyendo hectáreas
en Chile pero que también forja
hermandades entre dos pueblos Unidos por
el fin de derribar y ganar la batalla y
el terreno a las implacables llamas
y desde el Salvador revisamos la cifra
de la semana
4.564 denuncias de abusos registraron
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos durante la medida de
régimen de excepción implementada por el
presidente nayib bukele bajo el
argumento de disminuir las cifras de
criminalidad las mujeres se integrantes
de la comunidad lgbtiq más son las
principales Víctimas de acoso policial
violencia sexual o insultos ejercidos
por agentes de seguridad estatal
y también revisemos nuestra imagen de la
semana que llega desde París el premio
Nobel peruano Mario Vargas llosa se
convirtió en el primer escritor en hacer
parte de la academia francesa sin haber
redactado un texto en francés en su
discurso del autor defendió el papel de
la novela en las democracias y afirmó
que fue en Francia donde se descubrió
como escritor
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Giovanni agudelo
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web trans24.com y Para
más información de nuestro continente
Sigan viendo France 24
[Música]
Bienvenidos